I believe that this is the situation
Mika is in in his own nightmare he can't
wake up from it but instead goes with
the flow of the story within the
nightmare creating us to hopefully wake
him up by becoming Elden Lord and
changing the world just like he wanted
to could this be why we look up toward
micholas Halo tree when we defeat
melania's first stage I've always found
this to be very strange why is our
character looking up towards this trunk
where micholas cocoon was removed maybe
we feel some sort of strong connection
toward it I believe the DLC will be us
touching this hand of Mika and not
entering into mola's dream but waking
him up from it and us being transferred
along with him to the real lands between
that looks a lot like the picture we see
here the land covered in reads ruined
buildings and the UR tree being
completely taken over by Godwin's death
blight